Ever since the apparent disappearance of SCP-682,
The Hard-To-Destroy-Reptile, The SCP Foundation
had been growing restless.
All personnel aware of the situation were
filled with conflicted feelings of paranoia
and relief.
Perhaps at long last one of the universe’s
most hateful and dangerous anomalies was gone
for good, as there had been no trace of the
monster since the chemical plant explosion.
But given the keter-class reptile’s track
record with all methods of annihilation, none
of the researchers were too optimistic.
In reality, none of them had any idea that
the actual whereabouts of SCP-682 was five
levels deep into the sprawling, seemingly
endless labyrinth of liminal dimensions known
simply as The Backrooms.
It was a far crueler and more alien reality
than any punishment that The Foundation could
have dreamed up for the reptile, but nonetheless
it was the reality that SCP-682 had to face!
After rampaging for hours through what appeared
to be an infinite hotel, SCP-682 was finally
able to check out of his unexpected stay in
the level 5 resort.
As was becoming routine at this point, movement
between levels of The Backrooms came down
to finding an ideal surface to no-clip further.
In the case of the entrance to The Backroom’s
level 6, the hard to destroy reptile managed
to find such a location in the vast boiler
room of level 5.
With no reason to hesitate and frankly being
incredibly disgusted with the appearance of
human hospitality in the infinite hotel, SCP-682
vanished into the no-clip surface and re-emerged
into the evidently pitch-black void of level
6.
This new level was dark, absolutely so.
It was the kind of advanced darkness only
observed in the depths of our reality’s
largest cave systems, where no natural or
artificial light can reach.
SCP-682 was not deterred by this, of course.
The highly-adaptable organism had already
developed sophisticated echolocation sonar
in order to navigate the yellow wallpapered
maze of level one, as well as infrared night
vision which it had heavily utilized in level
two.
Though level 6 remained for all intents and
purposes concealed by darkness, SCP-682 evolved
senses could easily make sense of its layout.
Aside from the impenetrable shroud of darkness
that pervaded the entire level, the reptile
soon found level 6 to be largely familiar
territory.
Like every previous level of The Backrooms
that SCP-682 had traversed, this level took
the form of a seemingly random arrangement
of tight hallways that stretched on for a
fathomless distance in every direction.
More empty tunnels, you’ve got to be kidding
me…
SCP-682 thought to itself.
This latest infinite labyrinth was the most
infinite and labyrinthine of all the infinite
labyrinths that SCP-682 had wandered through
since it no-clipped into The Backrooms.
There was however something unusually calming
about this level, as if being here made the
reptile that much less driven to escape.
It still wanted more than anything to find
more living things to destroy, but on level
6: it was decidedly willing to take its time
and see how far these tunnels would go before
it got its next fix of violence.
What SCP-682 didn’t know is that the darkness
of level 6 was not merely a property of a
lack of lighting, and possessed the supernatural
ability to induce feelings of intense anxiety
and existential dread within any human being
unfortunate enough to be trapped within.
The emphasis being on the words “human being”,
which SCP-682 was anything but.
While the SCP’s sudden shift in attitude
might have been a side-effect of its adaptable
nature, it’s very possible that any sufficiently
malicious entity might feel right at home
on level 6.
Not that there appeared to be any other entities
present on this level.
Regardless, the reptile was having a grand
old time moving from hallway to hallway, and
for once it was starting to see the appeal
of delayed gratification.
It wasn’t overly concerned about not encountering
life on this floor, because in its omnicidal
mind, SCP-682 was thinking how much of a special
treat it would be to be able to destroy something
entirely new.
Whatever it might be.
For all the predictability of their mazelike
structure, The Backrooms were full of surprises.
Case and point, SCP-682’s recently adapted
echolocation picked up a single, isolated
humanoid figure several hundred miles away.
The reptile chuckled to itself.
Poor sucker.
This is too easy.
He began to leisurely maneuver towards the
lone humanoid, who curiously appeared to be
standing in that one place without any signs
of movement.
This pleased SCP-682, and when it eventually
made its way to the room where the humanoid
was located: it found that its latest prey
had been waiting patiently for the inevitable
doom that the creature would bring.
The strange humanoid, the only entity that
SCP-682 had encountered on level 6, appeared
to be an ordinary man standing next to an
enormous light switch on the wall.
“Pull the switch.
Please pull the switch,” the man repeated.
He was a sitting duck.
SCP-682 was going to relish this one.
The reptile moved forward with pointed aggression
and soon there was no man standing there:
only the switch he once begged passerby to
pull.
SCP-682 proceeded to exit the quiet room,
having no interest in the light switch or
what might happen if it were pulled.
Shortly thereafter, SCP-682 began to hear
scuttling sounds within the darkness, as if
a giant crustacean or insect were quickly
moving through the halls.
The sensory data that it was receiving from
its echolocation didn’t detect any nearby
forms of life, least of all any with an anatomy
that would correspond to those kinds of chitinous
sounds.
Before long, another sound became faintly
audible throughout level 6, that of crashing
ocean waves.
SCP-682 had nothing but time and no better
place to go, so it began to follow the sounds
towards their source.
Gradually, the tidal noises increased in volume
to the point that they even began to overwhelm
SCP-682’s very own sound waves of echolocation.
Although temporarily struggling for direction,
SCP-682 felt a sudden decline in the surface
of the floor beneath its feet.
It appeared to be a staircase, and the ocean
waves could be heard coming from just beyond.
As the reptile descended the stairs, the soothing
feelings that had accompanied it throughout
its journey across level 6 began to rapidly
dissipate.
When SCP-682’s claws touched down on the
final step, all traces of easy-going apathy
had fully faded and were replaced once again
with the boundless spite and malice that defined
its usual mindset.
It was pleasant while it lasted.
SCP-682 now found itself in a damp room full
of assorted furniture including a bookcase
with a few books, a coffee table, and a single
chair - non-glitched, to be precise.
The puddle of water on the floor beneath it
was about three inches deep.
The glow of a fluorescent ceiling lamp was
a stark departure from the utter darkness
of the previous hallways in level 6.
But of course it was different…
This was level 7 - or rather, the entrance
room to level 7.
SCP-682 had little reason to linger in this
place for long, as the furniture was neither
alive nor large enough to support its mass.
An open doorway adjacent to the staircase
appeared to lead to a great body of salt water
which was doubtlessly the source of the ocean
noises.
As SCP-682 continued its advance into this
new layer, it was suddenly met with a change
of gravity.
The moment that it stepped in front of the
doorway to the ocean, 682’s relative relationship
to the entrance room’s gravity shifted such
that through the doorway became decidedly
“down.”
In a hilariously undignified fashion, the
keter-class anomaly tumbled through the doorway
to level 7 proper and plummeted directly into
the vast sea below.
This was something new.
While level 7 was without a doubt another
impossibly huge liminal nightmare dimension
contained within The Backrooms, it wasn’t
another maze of hallways.
Or at the very least, it didn’t look like
one.
Though there was no visible sun anywhere on
the horizon, the blue sky up above the ocean
was well-illuminated as if to imply the presence
of daylight.
SCP-682 landed in the water beneath the entrance
room with a tremendous splash and instantly
its body began to sink deeper into what appeared
to be an immense, uncharted ocean without
a sea bottom.
Within seconds, SCP-682’s echolocation adjusted
to the underwater environment, becoming more
like that of a dolphin.
With this enhanced sonar, SCP-682 attempted
to detect if there were any living organisms
within the immediate area.
While the ocean was mostly devoid of any new
entities, as was starting to become customary
in these new levels, the SCP did discover
a series of barren rocky islands along the
surface of the water.
Additionally, there were bigger shapes in
the far distance, which the sonar could detect,
but due to their colossal size: the nature
of these unknown objects was well… unknown.
Some of the strange shapes were drifting slowly
through the deep, indicating that while the
ocean of level 7 was far from a thriving ecosystem,
it may yet contain other beings that SCP-682
could fight to the death.
In order to cross the ocean and find any of
these potentially formidable entities, SCP-682
would have to adapt its physical form once
again.
The first priority was for it to grow a set
of gills, allowing SCP-682 to breathe in this
underwater environment.
Then, its four reptilian limbs began to stretch
and flatten, developing into full-sized aquatics
flippers the likes which might be found on
a prehistoric whale or a liopleurodon.
With these newly-minted bad boys, SCP-682
could gracefully glide through the water like
the angriest submarine to ever voyage to seas.
If it cared for petty thrills or the sensation
of freedom, SCP-682 may have perceived this
experience as fun.
However, anything close to a non-negative
emotion that the SCP was capable of had been
left behind in level 6.
It was more furious than ever at its current
predicament, especially because the encounter
on the previous level had been so brief and
anticlimactic.
As the liopleurodon-mode SCP-682 zoomed deeper
into the watery depths of level 7, the bright
rays of daylight from the level’s sky became
more distant.
In this cooler and darker twilight zone, SCP-682
began to see bones floating in the water.
The scattered remains of humans and aquatic
creatures could be seen throughout this area
of level 7, all entirely picked clean, with
perfectly white bones on display.
While, typically, a creature being submerged
this deep into a terrestrial ocean from our
reality would result in a severe increase
in water pressure, level 7 appeared to remain
at a constant and manageable level of pressure
- insufficient to crush even an ordinary human
skeleton.
Not that this equivalent level of water pressure
would pose any threat or hindrance to SCP-682,
and it continued its descent away from the
Daylight Zone and further into the Twilight
Zone.
Some of the skeletons here were absolutely
titanic in size - clearly, these were the
massive drifting shapes that SCP-682’s dolphin
sonar had sensed from the surface.
Whatever these things were, they all met their
end a long time ago.
Frustrated that, once again, The Backrooms
had denied it a meaningful challenge, the
hard to destroy reptile almost didn’t see
the hostile entity darting towards it with
the intent to seek and destroy.
682 wasn’t the only creature in this ocean
with a numerical designation!
The so-called Entity 720, also commonly known
as Tiny – smashed through the floating skeletons
and landed a glancing blow on the SCP with
his massive spear.
“Who dares to trespass in my domain!”
Tiny shouted, the entity's bioluminescent
body glowing with arrogant pride.
Its words were telepathic, beamed directly
into SCP-682’s mind.
Naturally, 682 began to evolve telepathy of
its own in preparation to respond.
While the aquatic being was over twice the
size of SCP-682 and armed with a fearsome
weapon of whittled bone - no doubt carved
from one of the many primeval and unknowable
skeletons of level 7 - the keter-class anomaly
was not about to back down from this obvious
provocation.
“Your domain?”
682 growled.
“Should I take it that you are the ruler
of The Backrooms?
Is this where this condemnable labyrinth ends?”
Entity 720 laughed with an overconfident bluster
and spoke:
“This is level 7, and I’m afraid that
you’re a great many levels away from the
last one.
But don’t worry, simple beast, I can promise
you that this is the last level you’ll ever
see!”
SCP-682 decided he didn’t like this thing.
It was acting far too cocky for its own good.
“You’re a loathsome and disgusting piece
of work, aren’t you?”
Again the entity laughed in 682’s face.
“Likewise, puny lizard.”
He said.
“Shall I teach you to fear me?”
SCP-682 gnashed its teeth and exclaimed “That’s
my line!”
Neither of these monsters was backing down,
and it was clear that an epic battle between
the two of them was about to take place.
682 rushed in, jaws opened wide to deliver
a brutal bite, but Entity 720 was deceptively
fast for its size, and swung its spear into
682’s side, catching it mid-aquatic charge
and sending it careening into a cluster of
floating ribs.
As if showing off, “Tiny” twirled his
weapon with a flourish before unleashing a
lightning-fast barrage of powerful spear thrusts.
To its annoyance and surprise, SCP-682 could
feel its body sustaining damage over the course
of multiple impacts.
He hated to admit it, but this was one entity
from The Backrooms that wasn’t all talk.
In response to Tiny’s merciless attack,
plates of natural armor began to cover SCP-682.
This improved its defense, but the SCP still
needed to take the fight to the entity.
Or better yet…
682 dodged one of the incoming spear attacks
and clamped its teeth around the middle of
the weapon.
It bit down like a vice, crushing a bit of
the bone but - again, to its surprise - failing
to close its jaw completely and thus being
unable to break the spear.
“Did you think that my mighty spear would
break so easily?”
Tiny scoffed.
He whirled the spear through the water with
enough force to create a tumultuous whirlpool,
spinning 682 in circles in an attempt to disorient
it.
He placed both of his large hands on the lower
part of the spear and - with the precise swish
and flick motion of a fisherman casting a
line - launched the reptile flying through
the depths.
How could this be happening?
SCP-682 wondered.
It roared in anger, causing the water around
it to ripple with the intensity of its sound
waves.
This caused an unforeseen reaction in Tiny,
who hesitated and doubled back in response
to the noise.
SCP-682 grinned through its horrible teeth.
So that was its weakness?
Tiny recovered from the shock of 682’s roar
moments later, and it seemed like he was trying
to play his reaction off as disgust.
“Pathetic.
Now say good night!”
He said as he aimed to hit SCP-682 with his
most powerful weapon strike yet.
Tiny struck his foe with all the force he
could muster, running him through like he
was spear-fishing, but in response, SCP-682
released a high-pitch sonic screech that shook
the waters around both adversaries even more
than the last.
The impact of the sound waves was so powerful
that all surrounding skeletons began to shatter
into small shards of bone.
Tiny was hit straight on with the sonic vibrations
from SCP-682 sensory attack and was immediately
rendered unconscious - sinking like a stone
to the area even deeper below The Twilight
Zone: The Midnight Zone.
The fight between SCP-682 and Entity 720 was
effectively over.
SCP-682 shook off the entity’s final blow
and began to regenerate from all his injuries.
That telepathic creature had been by far the
most challenging thing that it had encountered
during its journey through The Back Rooms,
but the increase in durability to its own
armor would prove useful in protecting the
reptile from any other entities with a similar
level of brute force.
Diving after its fallen foe and hoping to
finish the job, SCP-682 entered into The Midnight
Zone.
It descended past several more vaguely humanoid
skeletons and countless fishlike skeletons
which seemed to have no real beginning or
end.
Apparently, the body of entity 720 had sunk
quickly out of reach of the SCP, or perhaps
Tiny had fled the battle out of fear.
While happiness and triumph were not within
its emotional capacity, SCP-682 did take a
wicked sense of glee in crushing that entity’s
stubborn pride.
It continued to swim directly downward, emboldened
by victory.
Eventually, SCP-682 came to the mouth of an
enormous cavern towards the end of The Midnight
Zone.
The opening appeared to be within the side
of a tall underwater mountain.
While the thought of having to travel through
more narrow spaces reminded it unfavorably
of its containment facility, SCP-682 was beginning
to accept The Backrooms rarely manifested
as open space.
If claustrophobic caves and corridors were
the one consistency, SCP-682 had long been
accustomed to those kinds of spaces.
Sure enough, entering the Midnight Mountain
soon revealed the entrance to the lair of
Sorceress!
- oh, my apologies - that’s a completely
different story about a feisty reptile traveling
through forgotten realms and defeating everything
in its path.
This isn’t Spyro Explained.
It’s SCP Explained, darn it!
Getting back on track, 682 arrived in a subterranean
system of rocky tunnels which – while no
longer entirely totally submerged – was
damp with water: almond water, because what
else?
This was The Backrooms level 8.
Despite the fact that the entrance to level
8 was beneath The Midnight Zone of level 7
and there appeared to be no natural source
of light, the visibility within these caverns
was surprisingly high.
It was to the point that even an average human
could, with little effort, perceive their
surroundings here.
Is this some kind of sick joke?
SCP-682 thought to itself.
If whoever trapped me in The Backrooms thinks
that they can contain me in a place humans
could survive, I must show them just how wrong
they are.
When I find them, it’s on sight.
Since 682 had already developed echolocation
and night vision, level 8 wasn’t exactly
a new frontier.
Yet, it began to dawn on the hard-to-destroy
reptile that this might be all that The Backrooms
was: a neverending collection of cavernous
new dimensions to wander aimlessly until it
stumbled across the entrance of the next level
by chance.
It could go on forever, with seemingly no
rhyme or reason.
Though the oceans of level 7 had presented
682 with the concept that the Backrooms might
have an outside that could be used as a means
to escape back into its native reality: the
truth appeared to be that there was no distinction
between an exterior and an interior within
these dimensions.
From the second it had no-clipped into this
place, SCP-682 might have been effectively
condemned to meander through infinite levels
of The Backrooms until the end of time.
Discouraged wasn’t the right word for how
682 was feeling.
It was far more accurate to say that the reptile
was absolutely fuming with barely restrained
rage for the unfathomable cosmic forces that
had brought it here.
They would all pay dearly for the disgusting
indignity it had suffered.
As SCP-682 progressed deeper into the winding
tunnels and echoing caverns of The Backrooms
level 8, it found itself surrounded once more
by a hostile swarm of death moths.
The larger females began to spit acid, melting
away portions of the armor its body had worked
so hard to adapt.
It always had to be acid.
SCP-682 let out a low rumbling noise that
sounded somewhat like a sigh of exasperation.
After his intense and thrilling battle with
Tiny, was he really going to have to return
to destroying these worthless bugs that even
those weak-kneed jelly bags on the mobile
task forces could handily dispatch?
“You idiot creatures!
Do you have any idea what you’re dealing
with here?”
SCP-682 grumbled.
The deathmoths didn’t respond, they merely
continued to flap around in the air around
the SCP’s head and bombard the reptile with
more acid.
682 was positively seething.
“KNOW YOUR PLACE!!”
It mercilessly devoured every last death moth
before making its way deeper into level 8.
Perhaps, with the myriad monsters said to
lurk in this level, SCP-682 would find itself
faced with another worthy challenger after
all…
Now go check out part one and two of the SCP-682
Vs The Backrooms series to relive all of the
insane, extra-dimensional reptile carnage
that brought us back to now!